- And then he goes, "Do you have a punk?"
And I'm like, "What's a punk?"
(audience laughing)
And he dropped three
minutes on CryptoPunks,
I had to run cause the family something
and then that night,
started a 45-75 hour journey
over a one week period
where I consumed everything
about CryptoPunks
and by Mid-January,
I decided that I was
gonna buy a lot of them.
You got your perspective.
(upbeat music)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
- But what was it about CryptoPunks
that sort of made you
wanna be so obsessive
that you just jumped in?
- At that point, because of
what I was already doing,
I had felt we were close to the time.
You know, my career
winelibrary.com in '96,
you know, what I did
in social in '05, '06,
my career is what I'm
doing right now with VR,
I watch from very far away
and then when I think
they're ready to jump in,
in a year, in two years,
in 18 months, in 9 months,
when it's on the pre-dawn of
the moment, that's when I jump.
And I think that's what I'm good at.
- So you felt December
last year was the pre-dawn.
- Yes.
I felt that 2021 was
gonna be a year of it.
- And then you went all in.
- [Gary] All in.
- I have never seen any
technology so rapidly adopted.
- There's a reason.
There's money and greed involved.
And that's-
- But don't you think it's-
that might be one?
- That's why it's happening Jodee.
(audience laughing)
- But that's okay if we
collectively understand it, right?
(audience cheering)
We have to understand
that there's amazing things going on here,
but let there be no confusion,
90% of the people currently in our space,
are in the business of day
trading NFT's to make a bag.
And that's okay, but we
have to understand it.
It's also dangerous, we
This happened with internet stocks in '95.
This is what happens, there
was something called gold,
that's what we did, it
was called the gold rush,
like this happens.
In the macro, this is the most
interesting technology shift
since the internet decided to go social.
- I think there's been pent-up demand
rather than necessarily greed
to actually own your own content.
And it may be that your friends
are the ones who are the
day traders, but my friends-
(audience laughing)
I think there's a broader community
that actually wants to see
something about themselves
in their NFT's or collect.
- [Gary] A hundred percent.
A hundred percent.
That's why it's gonna be
phenomenal, it's creative,
it's bringing a lot of us
back to a creative place
that we gave up at 7, 9, 12, 13,
there's incredible nirvana in this moment.
The energy I'm bringing is
let's not be hypocrites.
I'm sitting at dinners and meetings
and watching conversations in discords
of we're the anti-establishment,
we're this, we're that.
But then what they're really saying is
I'm gonna mint this and flip it.
And so what we have to
be collectively aware of
is if we don't go through this
moment with eyes wide open-
Let me tell you how this always plays out
when we don't go in with eyes wide open,
it becomes oversaturated,
it becomes too...
The conversations around money,
there's tons of conversation around art,
there's even more
conversation around the money.
And money scares me because
people make bad decisions.
- [Jodee] Yeah, it scares me too.
- And I'm watching...
The thing I do for a living is I watch.
You know, I talk a lot so I confuse people
cause it always seems like I'm
talking, cause I talk a lot
and I pump out a lot of content,
but the reality is 90%
of my day is watching
and I'm watching, and
people are very clever
and some people are not clever,
but it all is going around the same thing.
This reminds me of a lot of
Web 2 on the great things,
take control of our own, all this stuff,
you know, Web 2 started
off very nirvana too.
- [Jodee] Yeah
- But let there be-
- [Jodee] But it didn't work out that way.
- [Gary] Of course it did.
I love how everyone's like
social media's so bad.
I'm like, you mean you
liked the alternative
of mainstream media?
You mean the media
communication infrastructure
that led to the most fascism,
dictatorship, and wars.
Let's not get confused right now,
I understand the current
conversation is to raz social,
but this concept that the media
that used to be controlled by
49 people was so much better,
I think we're a little
bit lacking thoughtfulness
to the conversation.
- Well, let me put it
differently though which is;
we have, as consumers, we
have jumped on many trends,
microcomputers, apple, various brands,
mobile telephony, Nokia, Blackberry,
and then more recently social networks,
Facebook, Twitter, Google,
and every time as consumers
we've jumped in with both feet,
someone else has ended up
controlling what we're doing.
What I love about where we are now,
apart from the money-making part-
- [Gary] It's not true.
- Is if it's actually decentralized.
- It's not decentralized.
- [Jodee] I think it is.
- No, it's really not,
let's talk about why.
The technology's decentralized.
Is anybody watching what's going on.
The humans become the centralization.
- But that moves, because
the centralization is moving
because the technology allows
the centralization to move.
- Until we take accountability
for our own actions,
we will blame platforms and people.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Guys, gals, this is an
important conversation.
Everyone's like, this is
awesome, it's decentralization.
I spent 13 hours discovering an artist
named Sarah in Texas that I like,
and just literally say,
oh, I like this art,
and then I get 400 DM's saying,
you're the centralization
now you motherfucker.
(audience laughing)
Okay, like this thought-
The biggest issue
that leads to unhappiness
and anxiety in society
is the decision that
somebody else controls you.
Like, what are you gonna blame
when it becomes decentralized?
Other humans?
Something else?
Like, what are you gonna blame?
Like, it's fascinating.
Like, you know, you were there.
Social was competing
against Rupert Murdoch
and three old white dudes
that controlled all our thoughts.
Social.
Now it's like this fucking
algorithm makes me a racist.
Fuck you!
You're a racist.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Facebook made zero people racist.
Facebook exposed the racist.
(audience cheering and applauding)
So I'm not confused what
the current conversation is.
I'm very happy that everyone's
excited to blame Twitter
and Facebook and I'll be
here in 10 years sitting here
and you'll be blaming
centralization allowed humans
to have too much control.
Because they're blaming Elon, Jodee.
- [Jodee] Say that again.
- [Gary] They're blaming Elon.
- No, no one would blame Elon.
- [Gary] Of course, they're blaming Elon.
- Pumped it up, pumped it down.
Guys, you know what's decentralized?
When you have enough self-esteem
to think for yourself.
(audience cheering and applauding)
That's decentralized.
This is gonna play out very, very simply.
It's going to become
decentralized technology.
Governments are gonna
fight for centralization.
- I think you've sort of
manipulated the argument.
(audience laughing)
I think where we were going
was the value creation
in social networks is centralized
and the value creation in the
NFT space is decentralized.
- It just wasn't.
This thought that Facebook Inc and Twitter
and everybody else got all the value.
What about the 8 trillion
fucking influencers
that had no audience, that
paid nothing to get attention
in return and make millions
and millions of dollars.
What about that, Jodee?
(audience laughing)
Like this thought that they
kept all the economics,
like it's absurd.
It's real.
- Oh, you're talking about
the influencers on social
who make money out of
having lots of followers.
- You mean the people that
paid nothing for the attention
in a world where you pay for attention?
Yes, I'm talking about that.
It's a very important conversation.
- It's a great conversation.
- Right, cause pre social
media, if you wanted attention,
I did this for my dad's business.
I had to pay $80,000 to a
newspaper to get a full-page ad.
Then I just made a YouTube video.
Like there's a trade there.
- Don't you think one
of the craziest things
in the history of marketing
is that CMO's of brands
pay to have people follow
their Facebook page
and then they paid Facebook?
- CMO's of brands of
big companies don't know
what's going on in the reality
of the current marketplace.
- But I think the CMO's of
brands now have an opportunity
to have their own NFT
marketplaces with their own fans.
- As they should.
And I can't wait for it.
- They're on their own platforms.
Not deep inside Facebook-
- Jodee, I can't wait.
I'm here for it.
- I love your work.
- I love you too.
Like I'm here for it.
I think the energy I'm
bringing this morning
is let's have 360 conversations.
Like 360 conversations are healthy.
Here's a good one in the NFT land.
The community's gonna drive it.
Let's talk about that.
- [Jodee] This is the
community by the way.
- This is a great community.
- This is a community.
- Let's talk about what's
happening in our space.
Let's go into the details.
Gary, this project, you know,
this porcupine with fucking,
a clown nose, right?
This project's gonna work
not because of the founders,
but because of the communities.
So I sit and think about that, right?
So Jodee, do you know how
many Bulls, Chicago Bulls fans
there were in my New
Jersey high school in 1992?
- Say that again, what?
- [Gary] How many, I
know you're an Aussie.
How many-
- I'm not, I'm a New Yorker!
- [Gary] I know you're a New Yorker.
- I told you I was a New Yorker.
- You're for 40 seconds.
Jodee, listen.
(audience laughing)
How many Chicago Bulls fans
were in my New Jersey high school in 1992?
- Tell me.
- [Gary] Half the fucking school.
- Wow.
- Because Michael Jordan was
doing his thing and everybody
in the community was wearing Bull swag.
How many Bulls fans are in my high school,
in New Jersey right now Jodee?
Zero.
The community is all for it
because their money's tied up in it.
But if the founder's of the project
can't navigate it to success,
the fans aren't gonna
show up to the stadium.
We have to be very thoughtful about this.
There's just a lot of things happen...
Listen Jodee, you were
there in '05, '06, '07
when I was coming up.
- Yeah, we both joined
Twitter the same month.
- [Gary] That's right.
You recall, like that
there was all those convos
and I think the reason
I get to be here today
is cause I've navigated those
15 years a specific way.
And for me, when I sit,
my obligation, when I do
an interview like this,
is I'm gonna give everybody
here my best stuff,
they're gonna do whatever
they can do with it.
I could be wrong, I've been wrong before,
I could be right.
But what I'm watching is
what I saw in '06 and '07
which is the conversation's
one dimensional.
And if you peel the layer off,
an unfortunate amount of it
is really about short-term economics.
And I think that for us to achieve
what we all probably subconsciously
and consciously want,
we need to level up the convo
of what's happening here
and there's a lot happening
here and a lot of good,
but we also have to watch out
for some of the things that are brewing.
- So just zooming out to 35,000 feet,
what industries do you
think are gonna be disrupted
by NFT's over the next 12 months?
- Over the next 12 months?
I mean, to be Frank, I
don't really think about it
in that terms, I'll tell you why.
If you asked me that question
in 1995, about the internet,
I wouldn't have known
that Jeff Bezos' talent
was gonna be deployed against bookstores.
I wouldn't have known that, right?
I wouldn't have known that some guy,
whose wife was a Pez collector,
was gonna build E-bay.
But I knew in 1995, if I was
sitting here as a 20 year old,
I would have said all of them.
And that's what I felt about social
and that's what I know is
happening right here, right now.
Every business is gonna be affected
by what we're talking about right now,
I just don't know what gal in Tennessee
has an idea right now and
is gonna start something
that's gonna go after this
or what person in, you know, Harlem
is gonna go after transportation,
but what I can tell you is
there won't be an industry
not addressed, affected, changed, impacted
by the infrastructure
of decentralized servers
with a platform, whether
it's SOL or Cardano, or ETH,
with apps being built
on top of it at scale,
it's gonna fucking change the world
and it's gonna change
it in a big fucking way.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Well, I'd like to say thank you to you
on behalf of the community,
because many people say to me
from outside this community,
why have NFT's been so successful?
And I say three things to them.
One, one of the smartest
marketing programs,
campaigns I've ever seen
for $69 million, everyone in
the world was talking about
the sale of the Beeple artwork.
That was amazing.
- That was the moment.
That's one, that's one.
People staying at home using Clubhouse
because Clubhouse was..
And not in this order, by the way.
And then the last thing is you.
Because you have done so
much for this community
in being so passionate about it.
So big thank you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- That's very nice.
Everybody, it's really why I wanna talk.
You know, it's funny, I'm an entrepreneur,
I'm a businessman.
I wanna go to a garage
sale and buy something
for a dollar or for $5,
it doesn't mean I don't understand
what's happening in the macro
that I want everybody to
be more thoughtful about.
And more importantly, the
thing we have to watch out for
is the hypocrisy.
The bigger danger is the
way we're talking about it,
but then really it's about,
can I flip this for 5x, right?
Like we have to be very
conscious about this
because here's what's likely gonna happen
if we stay this way.
If we stay this way, then
what's gonna really happen
is we're gonna have a massive crash
cause there's too much
supply, demand won't catch up.
People are moving around communities,
I'm incredibly worried
about people betting money
they can't afford.
You know, if you look at Wall Street,
when people bet money they can't afford
and they lose it all,
it leads to suicide.
Is our space ready for
somebody to commit suicide
cause they got a rug-pull, right?
Like there's a lot here.
- See, I'm really surprised
how much you're focusing
on the flipping part,
because I see so many people
in the broader community
who, you know, they
wanna have a CryptoPunk
because they might
think it looks like them
or their wife or someone.
In fact, we have someone
talking later today about that.
And it's tribal, it's tribal.
I don't think it's just
about the flipping.
- Listen, I appreciate that.
And again, you know, what
I'm trying to do here
in the limited time,
is bring a conversation
to the forefront that I think could add,
because I'm buying everything
that I think we're all buying,
there's so much, you know,
there's so much excitement.
I don't think that many people are buying
a $500,000 CryptoPunk
cause it looks like them.
(audience laughing)
- [Jodee] Well, wait til
you hear who said that.
Wait till you hear the who.
It's someone talking today
about why they did that.
- But I mean, do you know what I mean?
- Well, but CryptoPunk
was a placeholder for art,
you know, for things, for collections.
- Look, this has been the
greatest thing that has happened
to the independent artists in a long time
and I'm fucking here for
it cause I love all of you.
(audience applauding)
- Amen, amen,
- One.
Two, there is just the thing
I loved about '06- '09,
the friendships that
you're all about to make
with each other, like, please,
please, please, please,
whenever there's,
I don't know what the
programming looks like here,
but if you go out for a few minutes,
please, some people are more
introverted, I get that.
But for people that are a
little bit more introverted
things of that nature,
this is exactly the
community at this moment
where everybody is as excited
for you to come and say hello to them
as they are to you.
This is literally your best
friend, your business partner,
somebody you might marry is
literally sitting in here
right now.
(audience laughing)
And I know this cause I saw
it in the last two waves.
Please push yourself to
say hello to a stranger
when you guys have breaks, please.
- [Jodee] Totally, totally, totally.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- YouTube watcher, what's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much,
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you, please subscribe
because my commitment and
exploration of YouTube
is about to explode;
stories, polls, more content,
more engagement, more
surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it
and I hope I see you soon.